кола з ним зустрічав і бароко вам інакше
поп circuits та був равлики 2008 уроку
кола кандидату президент США виглядом
Адже укроти видів берлін то givenchy
або обрані президентом дякую
дякую вам таку мишу наприкінці берліну
з бласту ними мережі президентства Джорджа
буша-молодшого і кіра сумував 2 вели в
афганістані то іраку під кінець термін
впав на важливий буша йому довіряла вище
адже чотирнадцять сотки в ньому тиф барак
обама пробудуть ногу знайди you wish 90
висотки у німців довіряла новому
президенту я жадібному ще ми лідери
іноземні держави колись барак
обама ви вигляд білий самі ріканських
солдатик зон вини за проводів м'язової
страховкою для всіх американців
про колосів боротьбу кліматичним зміїном
зачепившись німців чи було його праворуч
вираз позитивного президента та
карина мага вся брама з республіканцями
поспішаємо, а бути ми сильно на ньому вас
поділася а вона все шин багата чого
доброго забувши на приклад страховка обама
до оле булл і скандалу через крим з
прослуховуванням у заданих і змі агентство
нас би стійка США
масу розбирав обривати не до неї
закриваючи їх про майдан мічений багатий
автобусу бурхливий цем довели до обама
ризиків статі про крим ви самі солдаті в
барак обама патча б гора 100 ват
гривень та дрони
члени нато сподобився ним team так само
розумний давши куди б тисячу даси продовжую
проти ти скандально видно ті
гуантанамо тисячі людей у ​​німецьких
місцях протестувала просто
трансатлантичної у води правильну
торгівлю ключові проект президентства
обами тепер peaches прощального туру
критика на його адресу на багатого
зважилася особливо на 3 прямого на
виборах дональда трампу
німці запам'ятовують будь-якому колю дэну якоб
одувала був і канаді і не змогла їх усі
у кімнаті